Speaker 1: Let's start today with the prosecution
of Dr. Anthony Fauci, which is not a thing and it
won't be and he won't be prosecuted. But it is
a really interesting sort of entry point or lens
into what the House of Representatives has become
under the control of Republicans that started
in January on the basis of Republicans winning
control in November of 2022, not of the Senate,
but yes, of the House of Representatives.
Everything of note that the Republican controlled
House of Representatives has involved itself
in publicly since they've taken over has been
a joke and in some cases has actually backfired
completely. The hearings on the weaponization of
government humiliation, just pathetic humiliation,
the hearings about big tech and Hunter Biden. And
so just an embarrassment, a global embarrassment
to the extent that the rest of the world is paying
attention to this nonsense, but importantly,
virtue signaling for the small group of people
that care, including the members of Congress,
that treat hearings as a way to audition to be
on HANNITY or Tucker's shows later that day,
Fine. There is a sort of persistent phrase
that won't go away from the lexicon as my chair
collapses from the lexicon of some on the right,
which is prosecute. Fauci Yes. Dr. Anthony
Fauci, now 82 years old, has been working for
the government in a health role for quite
literally decades. They want to prosecute
him and many of them are saying forget about
prosecute jail. Fauci imprisoned. Fauci. Okay.
Why do they want to do that? I don't really know.
And we're going to look at a clip of CNN's Jim
Acosta asking Dr. Fauci, what do you think about,
you know, Elon Musk tweeting, my my pronouns are
prosecute. What do you think about the people
calling to prosecute you? And Fauci says,
I don't know what they would prosecute me for.
Speaker 2: I think I wanted to ask you, you know,
you've been vilified on the far right. I know you
know that. Yeah. And we've seen Elon Musk tweet
that his pronouns, he's the owner of Twitter,
that his pronouns are prosecute Ford. You guys
in the GOP have talked about arresting you and
prosecuting you for your handling of COVID. What's
your response to that? Your response to Musk, and
what has that been like for your family? Yeah.
Well, I mean, there's no response to that
craziness, Jim. I mean, prosecute me for
what? What are they talking about? I mean, I wish
I could figure out what the heck they were talking
about. I think they're just going off the deep
end. Yes. The answer to your first question, it
doesn't make any sense to say something like that.
And it actually is irresponsible. Of course, it's
going to have a difficult affect and a deleterious
effect on my family. I mean, they don't like
to have me getting death threats. Right. Every
time somebody gets up and spouts some nonsense,
that's misinformation, disinformation and outright
lies, somebody somewhere decides they want to do
harm to me and or my family. So that's the part
about it that is really unfortunate. The rest of
it is just insanity, the things they're saying.
But it does have a negative effect when people
take it seriously and take it out on you and your
family, which is the reason why I still have to
have protection, which is really unfortunate.
Speaker 1: It's not only unfortunate that Dr.
Fauci needs security at this stage of the game
or at any stage of the game. It's insane that
the right has allowed themselves to be led down
this absurd path wherein a doctor who simply is
trying to do what's best to most to save and
help the largest number of people possible
has become not only the target of like, Oh, he
might have been wrong about certain things at
certain points. Okay. Right. Well, we could talk
about that. But this is a criminal. This is an
evil person. He created COVID, which is one
that's been floating around. And of course,
that he should be prosecuted. Now, let's play it
out. Out of curiosity, I did some research to try
to figure out what exactly do they want Dr. Fauci
prosecuted for. I don't know how many of you know
this. I mean, if I before I tell you, what would
you guess they want him prosecuted for? It seems
that the most common refrain is Fauci should be
prosecuted for lying to Congress, which is not
really a mishandling of COVID, particularly when
a lot of these very same right wingers said that,
you know, all of the Trump people prosecuted
for lying either to Congress or investigators,
that's not really a crime. Well, now they want
Fauci prosecuted for that. But what was it that
Fauci said that they say is a lie? Well, when
Dr. Fauci said the federal government has not
funded gain of function research at the Wuhan
Institute for Virology, these right wingers say
that that was lying to Congress under oath and
worthy of prosecution. Well, what's the truth
of that? It's a very shaky basis for prosecuting.
First of all, scientists aren't in agreement as
to whether what was happening, as to whether the
research being done is really gain of function.
Gain of function is a general term. And you can
find scientists who will disagree as to whether
any gain of function research was being done at
the Wuhan Institute of Virology. That's number
one. Number two, even if gain of function research
was being done at the Wuhan Institute of Virology,
what they're referring to is an Na H Grant
recipient and now called ego health. And the issue
is that EcoHealth did not file a report about what
they were doing, which is their fault. Ego health
is in the wrong because they didn't file a
report saying what exactly they were doing.
But that certainly suggests that at minimum,
when Dr. Fauci said what he said under oath, he
believed that he was telling the truth, even if it
turns out that there was gain of function research
being done to the satisfaction of every medical
science professional, which there is not. There
is every reason to believe that Dr. Fauci believed
he was telling the truth when he was under oath. I
can assure you there will be no prosecution over
that. And it relates to the same reason that you
rarely see prosecutions for perjury for witnesses
in criminal trials. Witnesses in criminal trials
say things that aren't true all the time, and
it is extraordinarily difficult to prove that
they knew they were saying things that were
false. And that's why you very rarely see a
perjury prosecution. So that's what it is.
If you're wondering, well, prosecute Fauci.
What is that all about? This is what it is all
about. And Dr. Fauci is confused, as any of us,
as to why resources would be spent in that way.
But they want to do the hearings. They want to
bring Fauci down. They want to make the whole dog
and pony show happen. I expect that they will.
But there is not going to be any prosecution
of Dr. Anthony Fauci, and that's a good thing.